You are just about to upload something to the Internet,...
...and suddenly, an error message on your browser pops up.
You then start to panic and hit the refresh button like crazy,...
...only to realize that your Internet connection is down.
You call tech support, who asked you to reset both the modem and the router.
That sounds easy, right?
Wait, you're upstairs, and your modem and router is somewhere in the jungle below.
You get your flashlight, find the right cable, unplug the modem,...
...unplug the wireless router, wait for 60 seconds,...
...plug in the modem, wait for the lights, then plug the wireless router and you're done.
Congratulations!
You then go back upstairs and hope the Internet is back online.
That sure took a lot of your precious time.
Why hasn't somebody invented a magic jelly bean that can fix everything with just the push of a button?
Guess what?
We just did.
Introducing the Amazing Jelly Bean.
The Amazing Jelly Bean is a device that allows you to reset your Internet connection...
...with just one push of a button.
You simply plug your modem and router into the magic jelly bean once.
And the next time you lose your internet connection, press the button and you're done.
Internet connection down?
No problem.
Your modem and wireless router in hard-to-reach places?
Can't see this video?
Then you need the Amazing Jelly Bean now.
Now resetting your Internet connection is a treat.